well I don't know if you've been able to
follow the the latest news revolving
around the church sex abuse scandal over
the last couple of days I know there's
been a lot of a lot of blood of big news
out there but this is this this
development is truly massive it is is
breathtaking
words words really fail to describe it
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do my best to
unpack this and to kind of break it down
for you and I'll give a few thoughts of
my own but my main point here the main
thing I want to do is just kind of give
you the basics of this because it's kind
of hard to follow along so Pope Francis
has been accused of personally when he
was Pope personally covering up sexual
abuse this accusation comes from us from
an archbishop Carlo Maria Vigano who's a
former papal nuncio to the United States
that's basically an ambassador for the
Vatican so this is a high-ranking person
this is not some random nobody okay this
is a person with intimate knowledge of
what's going on with intimate knowledge
of the inner workings of the church and
the hierarchy this isn't a conspiracy
theorist on a blog somewhere this isn't
a guy ranting in his car okay because
why would you want to listen to somebody
like that this is this is one of the
guys who has been in the upper echelon
of the church hierarchy and now he's
spilling his guts which is absolutely
incredible
the allegations revolve around Cardinal
McCarrick who was one of the most
powerful was one of the most powerful
Catholics in the United States in the
world really and it's recently been
revealed that Cardinal McCarrick is a
serial pervert and an abuser he's been
accused many accusations gonna against
them he's been accused of molesting two
children but the lion's share and that's
the only reason that we're finding out
about everything involving mckarrick is
because of those accusations but the
lion's share of his alleged sins have to
do with his behavior with young priests
and seminarians he's been accused of
groping assaulting abusing young priests
and seminarians
he's been accused of using seminaries as
as if they're you know some kind of gay
prostitution house where he would come
in and select his own little harem of of
homosexual seminaries and and and
seminarians and priests and he would
take them back to his beach house or
whatever and they would have gay orgies
and all these kind of thing I mean this
is just just he was a deviant pervert
abuser and disappear like with Weinstein
in Hollywood this was an open secret
from secret for many years in the church
although the secret was not open or
known among average lay Catholics this
was a secret openly known by many
bishops and Cardinals and if you believe
Vigano
the Pope as well Pagano discharged his
accusations in a stunning 11 page
document I cannot begin to summarize
everything that he says but again I
emphasize this is somebody who has you
seventy seven years old now he's been in
the church he's been in the hierarchy of
the church for many many years he has
seen a lot of things he's heard a lot of
things
he's documentation for a lot of things
he's been involved in many conversations
and now he is just pouring it all out
and saying look this is what this is
what I know and he's putting it all out
there he essentially drops so it's worth
reading the entire report if you haven't
done that he essentially drops an atomic
bomb on the entire network of cowards
and perverts in the church he names
names he calls out some of the
highest-ranking people in a church
accuses them of lying conspiring
covering up or of actually being
homosexual predators themselves he tells
a story about an actual conspiracy of
homosexuals and homosexual defenders in
the church who have worked in tandem
together to keep men like mckarrick in
positions of power this is something
that little old people like myself and
many others have been saying he exists
in the church an actual high-ranking
powerful network of homosexual predators
we've been saying this for a long time
that that exists and now you have
someone who's
the nose who has seen it for himself and
he is saying yes it's yes that that
exists and this is not just a crackpot
making up accusation this is like you
know this is the equivalent of this will
be like if Nikki hailey came out and
made
accusations against the Trump
administration that's that's what it
would be like about halfway through the
document so he spends the first half
calling out one after another naming
names a lot of names that you know most
of us have never heard before although
these are powerful people in church um
but he's he's good one after the other
he's calling people out he's putting her
names out there about halfway through
Vigano talks about Francis and he
alleges that Pope Francis knew
personally about mckarrick s-- abuses he
says that he Vigano personally had a
conversation about McCarrick with
Francis so that's how he he knows that
Francis knew because he spoke with him
about Francis so he knows this isn't
something he got second hand he knows it
personally let me
here's how he recounts a conversation he
had with Francis about McCarrick he says
I'm quoting for him him now he says the
Pope asked me asked me in a deceitful
way what is Cardinal McCarrick like now
the reason he says that this was
deceitful is because Vigano alleges that
Francis already knew about McCarrick he
knew all about him
and yet he was asking this question
pretending like he didn't know so yes
asks me what is Cardinal Carrick like I
answered him with complete frankness and
if you want with great naivete a holy
father I don't know if you know Cardinal
McCarrick but if you ask the
Congregation for bishops there's a dulce
ere this thick about him
he corrupted generations of seminarians
and priests and Pope Benedict ordered
him to withdraw to a life of prayer and
penance the Pope did not make the
slightest comment about those very grave
words of mine it did not show any
expression of surprise on his face as if
he had already known the matter for some
time and he immediately changed the
subject
later on Vigano says he had a similar
conversation with Cardinal Wuerl about
McCarrick yet whorl has since pretended
that in carton and whirl was was the
bishop and in Pittsburgh he's the one
he's been accused of covering up sex
abuse crimes whirl has pretended ever
since the information came out about
McCarrick whirl has said oh I had no
idea about this I'm so shocked and
horrified and and saddened by it but if
you Gallo says says that war will quote
lies shamelessly called him a shameless
liar so he knew about it because I
talked with him about it as to the Pope
it is alleged that Francis even after we
got o established that Francis knew
about the abuses and you'd talk to
Francis about it Francis still kept
mckarrick in positions of power and
visibility allowing him to continue in
his predations
took no action against him until a few
years later when the public found out
about mckarrick and then he took actions
against what's more the Gallo says that
that that Pope Benedict before Francis
eventually found out about mckarrick
when he was Pope he didn't find out
sooner even though people had made an
effort to let Benedict know about what
about what mccarroll McCarrick had been
up to and Vigano himself had sent memos
to the Vatican to alert Pope Benedict as
to the situation
but according to Vigano there were there
people high up in the Vatican who were
keeping that information from Benedict
but he did find out eventually he
sanctioned McCarrick forbidding him from
serving the church in any kind of public
way requiring him to go into seclusion
into a life of penance and fasting and
the guy too alleges that Francis
actually lifted those sanctions and
reinstalled mckarrick despite knowing
that McCarrick is a predator deviant he
lifted the sanctions and put him back in
public life where he could continue
doing what he'd been doing Vigano then
calls for a francis to step down
which is
think about this is is is incredible but
to have someone in his position calling
for the pub to resign is it it just it
does not happen very often this is a
kind of thing that hardly ever happens
so that's the summary of the report
what else has happened since then well
one of the men mentioned in began OHS
report a Monsignor Jean Francois has
corroborated the report Vigano says that
John Francois told him about the
sanctions a Benedict placed on McCarrick
and now Jean Francois has given a
two-sentence statement to the media
saying Vigano said the truth that's all
so that's a corroboration also a bishop
from Texas and Cardinal Burke have both
come out so that they think that the
report is that the accusations are
credible and that there needs to be a
full investigation into them on the
other side defenders of the Pope have
made a few points number one they've
claimed that Vigano himself it covered
up sexual abuses years ago and they
indicted his credibility by saying that
hey you know if he knew about all this
stuff why why didn't he come out earlier
and say it why is he waiting till now
now I don't know if the first thing is
true or not I don't know if he's guilty
of his own cover-ups but both of these
points really do nothing to absolve
Francis because in fact Vigano said
himself in his report it tells us why
he's coming out now and he says it's
because he's an old man and he's looking
to clear his conscience he knows he's
gonna be standing before God before long
and he doesn't want to go to God with
all of this on his conscience so he's
he's letting it out now he's trying to
do the right thing now near the end
before he has to face God
so what guilty or innocent he personally
is it's kind of irrelevant
number two they have poked holes in the
claim that Benedict sanctioned McCarrick
pointing out that McCarrick was still
celebrating mass was still going to
other functions and everything under
under Benedict maybe this means that the
sanctions never occurred maybe it means
they did but McCarrick defied them this
the the whole thing about the sanctions
that's one of the only things in the
ganas report that he got secondhand okay
he he heard about them and he says he
heard about them from this Monsignor
Jean Francois who has said corroborated
most of the other stuff it's not
secondhand he's saying these are
conversations I personally had with the
Pope and with others in the church so
the sanctions never happened I don't
know but whether there were sanctions or
not doesn't doesn't actually matter
the real question the real question is
did Frances know about McCarrick
that's it that's I mean that's it that's
that's the question did Francis know
about Meharry before all of this came
out in the media because if he did then
we know he's guilty of covering for him
because we know that he took no action
against McCarrick until all this came
out and that he did he had McCarrick in
a position of power and visibility where
he could you know he had access to
priests and seminarians and everything
else whether he was restored to power or
simply allowed to remain in power is
irrelevant actually all that matters is
whether Francis knew that McCarrick was
a predator and deviant and yet allowed
him to continue that's what matters
finally Pope Francis on the plane on the
way home from Ireland was asked about
this report and
now you would think put yourself in Pope
Francis's shoes you're the Pope okay and
you've just been accused of this this
this stunning accusation has just been
leveled against you by someone who was
high up in the church and someone who
wrote an 11 page report detailing not
just accusations against you but against
many members of the hierarchy and people
that are around you and that accusation
comes out if it weren't true
if it was all fake and made-up and false
because that's what we have to be that's
kind of that's the situation that we're
in either it's true or Archbishop Vigano
is a desperate liar who at the age of 77
has concocted this whole story and of
whole cloth and it for some reason and
and is is you know his putting it out
there even though he stands to gain
absolutely nothing from it whatsoever
but if that were the case you know
you're the Pope and somebody just
invented this story and you're given the
chance to clarify things
you would think you'd be very eager to
say no this is false it didn't happen
it's it's it is simply false but that's
not what the Pope said the Pope on the
plane he was asked by CBS about this and
this is what he said he said I will
respond to your question but I would
prefer that we first speak about the
trip and then other topics this morning
I read that statement I read it and I
will say sincerely that I must tell you
all this you CBS and all you who are
interested read the statement carefully
yourselves and make your own judgment
I am not going to say a word about this
I believe that the statement it speaks
for itself
and you all have sufficient journalistic
ability to draw conclusions it is an act
of trust when a little time goes by and
you have drawn conclusions perhaps I
will speak about it but I would like
your professional maturity to do this
work it will do you all good
really
what
what
I mean this is incredible Francis was
asked directly if he knew about
McCarrick if he lifted sanctions
these are simple yes or no answer it's
not it's not complicated there's no
nuance to it you either knew about him
but you did
if you didn't then you just say no I
didn't know about him there's absolutely
no reason to to refrain from saying no I
didn't know about him I didn't know it
it's not true
and if you didn't live sanctions then
again no that's a couple it's crazy I
didn't ever happened
but instead he refuses to answer the
question and even encourages people to
make up their own conclusions what
and then even even chides the media and
says and says like it'll be a character
building exercise for them to draw their
own conclusions
which is exactly what they're not
supposed to do in fact the news news
media is not supposed to draw its own
conclusions about things like this
they're supposed to do what they did
which is go to the Pope go to the source
and ask him did this happen get both
sides of the story and Pope Francis is
saying I'm not gonna give you my side of
the story
now there are only two ways to interpret
this from Francis only two is one he's
guilty too he has so much disdain for
the faithful in his church and so much
hubris that he doesn't think he that he
doesn't think he owes an explanation now
it's possible that both of these
explanations are true at once or maybe
one of them but there is no flattering
interpretation for Pope Francis here
refusing to answer the question either
way this is a
despicable response from Pope Francis
he's being accused of a very serious
infraction and people are calling him on
him to step down in disgrace from the
papacy which which again never happens
and he doesn't even bother to respond
what
you don't even give a response and not
only that but I mean forget about the
media forget about Pagano or anyone of
that any other bishop or Cardinal
whoever uh just the faithful okay the
his flock the faithful in the church are
reading about this stuff and they are
greatly distressed and troubled and and
I mean
plenty out there who are teetering on
the edge of despair over all this stuff
and this is Pope Francis's response draw
your own conclusions I won't respond
as a service it's despicable
um
here's what I'll say
if these allegations are true then
Francis has to resign and if you won't
resign then he has to be pushed out
there has to be an outcry so loud from
every Catholic and every good bishop and
priest that he has no choice but to
resign and disgrace if they're true
because then he whacks the moral
capacity to hold the office that he
holds and he simply cannot
continue holding
are the allegations true as the next
question
well we know that they're from a
credible source and they're from a
source who provides dates and quotations
and says that he has further
documentation we also know that he
claims in the report that it will be
corroborated by at least one of the
person it is corroborated by that person
the allegations are as I said
breathtaking but not fantastical not
unbelievable they are perfectly
reasonable allegations and they fit with
what we already know
doesn't make them true but I think
anytime somebody comes out with
allegations like this you have to look
and does it kind of fit in to the
picture that we already does it's like
when you're doing a putting together a
puzzle and you know you see there are a
lot of blank spaces and then you pick up
a piece and you can look like does this
does this piece even belong to this
puzzle or not you should be able to at
least tell that much based on what
you've already put together and so in
that sense it does appear to be a piece
of the puzzle that belongs to this
puzzle
so we know all that
and we also know that the Pope refused
to refuse the respond
one other point about that the only like
I said refusing to respond when you're
accused of something like this
it could be that you're guilty and so
you you don't want to say anything yet
because you got to go back and you got
to talk to your lawyers and you got a
craft uh you talk to your PR people and
you've got to talk to whole team of
people and craft what your response is
gonna be that that's only if you're
guilty not if you're innocent that it's
right
if somebody comes up to you and says if
police come up to you and say you're
accused of murdering so-and-so did you
do it and you didn't do it then you
don't I mean you venture you'll talk to
it you'll get a lawyer as well if you're
arrested but but right off the bat you
would say no I didn't do that of course
you would deny it if you didn't do it
there'll be no reason to refuse to deny
it if it didn't happen
I think much of the time the only the
only the only time when you really
refuse to say anything even to issue a
denial of something that of a very clear
accusation is if there's at least some
truth to it and so you need to figure
out how to craft it but then the other
as I said the other the other
explanation is that you you
have disdain for the person asking the
question and you think that the
accusations are so ridiculous that they
aren't do a response
now that is that's like there's there's
a video of a but Buzz Aldrin he was
confronted a few years ago by a moon
landing conspiracy theorist one of these
guys that thinks the moon landing never
happened and Alderon refuses to respond
to him and that eventually just punches
him in the face which is great by the
way just think that's awesome
I refuse to respond just plant clocks
the guy in the face now that is an
appropriate response because the claim
that you faked the moon landing is so
stupid so ridiculous so beneath it's so
really contemptible that it is not do an
answer except for a punch in the nose
this doesn't fall into that
because we already know
that there has been a far-reaching
conspiracy within the hierarchy of the
church to cover up sexual abuse we know
that perfect
so this is not a moon landing conspiracy
and when you're asked about it
your moral duty to respond and if it's
not true to issue that clarification and
to give reassurance to the faithful and
to all people around the world
so as I said if it is true than he has
to resign
whether or not it is true I guess we can
at this point say with a hundred percent
say you know say with 100% certainty
whether or not it is I think that
they're they're credible and I will say
that I'm inclined to
if I have to choose between believing
somebody like Archbishop Vigano
and believing the Cardinal Wuerl
Cardinal McCarrick and now Pope Francis
contingent I am going to be more
inclined to believe the former
either way these are very troubling
times and many more bishops aside from
just two of them need to speak up and
say there has to be a full investigation
into this we need a full investigation
no more messing around with it and if
there is any truth to these allegations
then Pope Francis has to go thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed